[Music]
in the 16th century Flemish physician
Andres Vesalius described how a
suffocating animal could be kept alive
by inserting a tube into its trachea and
blowing air to inflate its lungs in 1555
this procedure didn't warrant much
acclaim but today vas aliases treatise
is recognized as the first description
of mechanical ventilation a crucial
practice in modern medicine to
appreciate the value of ventilation we
need to understand how the respiratory
system works we breathe by contracting
our diaphragms which expands our chest
cavities this allows air to be drawn in
inflating the alveoli millions of small
sacs inside our lungs
each of these tiny balloons is
surrounded by a mesh of blood filled
capillaries this blood absorbs oxygen
from the inflated alveoli and leaves
behind carbon dioxide when the diaphragm
is relaxed the co2 is exhaled alongside
a mix of oxygen and other gases when our
respiratory systems are working
correctly this process happens
automatically
but the respiratory system can be
interrupted by a variety of conditions
sleep apnea stops diaphragm muscles from
contracting asthma can lead to inflamed
airways which obstruct oxygen and
pneumonia often triggered by bacterial
or viral infections attacks the alveoli
themselves invading pathogens kill lung
cells triggering an immune response that
can cause lethal inflammation and fluid
buildup all these situations render the
lungs unable to function normally
but mechanical ventilators take over the
process getting oxygen into the body
when the respiratory system cannot these
machines can bypass constricted Airways
and deliver highly oxygenated
air to help damaged lungs diffuse more
oxygen there are two main ways
ventilators can work pumping air into
the patient's lungs through positive
pressure ventilation or allowing air to
be passively drawn in through negative
pressure ventilation in the late 19th
century ventilation techniques largely
focused on negative pressure which
closely approximates natural breathing
and provides an even distribution of air
in the lungs to achieve this doctors
created a tight seal around the
patient's body either by enclosing them
in a wooden box or a specially sealed
room air was then pumped out of the
chamber decreasing air pressure and
allowing the patient's chest cavity to
expand more easily in 1928 doctors
developed a portable metal device with
pumps powered by an electric motor
this machine known as the iron lung
became a fixture in hospitals through
the mid 20th century however even the
most compact negative pressure designs
heavily restricted a patient's movement
and obstructed access for caregivers
this led hospitals in the 1960s to shift
towards positive pressure ventilation
for milder cases this can be done
non-invasively often a face mask is
fitted over the mouth and nose and
filled with pressurized air which moves
into the patient's airway but more
severe circumstances require a device
that takes over the entire breathing
process a tube is inserted into the
patient's trachea to pump air directly
into the lungs
with a series of valves and branching
pipes forming a circuit for inhalation
and exhalation in most modern
ventilators an embedded computer system
allows for monitoring the patient's
breathing and adjusting the airflow
these machines are used as a standard
treatment but rather as a last resort
in during this influx of pressurized air
requires heavy sedation and repeated
ventilation can cause long-term lung
damage but in extreme situations
ventilators can be the difference
between life and death and events like
the kovat nineteen pandemic have shown
that they're even more essential than we
thought
because current models are bulky
expensive and require extensive training
to operate most hospitals only have a
few in supply this may be enough under
normal circumstances but during
emergencies this limited cash is
stretched thin the world urgently needs
more low-cost and portable ventilators
as well as a faster means of producing
and distributing this life-saving
technology some life-saving inventions
aren't as technologically complex as
ventilators take for example the humble
bar of soap learn why soap is so
effective at fighting the corona virus
or what exactly a corona virus is with
these videos
[Music]